[Music]
hi my name is kelly bajanke and i'm an
assistant professor in the department of
neurosurgery at baylor college of
medicine
i wanted to start by giving a big thank
you to the organizers for putting all
this together and for the invitation to
speak today
i have the privilege of sharing with you
a set of experiments we've undertaken to
leverage the insights of stereotactic
eeg
in order to inform deep brain
stimulation therapy for treatment
resistant depression
the first part of this talk will
describe the design and philosophy of
the study the second part we'll discuss
the intracranial monitoring period and
our approach to characterization of the
trd network
and then the third part discusses our
efforts at mapping the depression
circuitry using multimodal fusion across
imaging and electrophysiology
so just to give a brief background there
are several brain targets undergoing
active investigation for the treatment
of treatment resistant depression
they're indicated here the current study
focuses on the first two the central
capsule ventral striatum target and the
subclosal cingulate target
we're investigating these targets
simultaneously
so implanting bilateral leads in the
central capsule ventral striatum and
also bilaterally in the subclosal
cingulate at the same time
during that surgery we're also placing
10
stereotactic eeg electrodes which are
temporary so they're kept in the brain
for the intracranial monitoring period
and then at the end of that period
they're removed
and the patient begins an open label
deep brain stimulation
therapeutic optimization phase
so just to say a little bit more about
the stereo eg approach so this approach
is borrowing from a routine diagnostic
practice in the surgical treatment of
epilepsy
wherein
temporary depth electrodes are implanted
in the brain connected to recording
equipment and then patients are
monitored during a hospital stay that
typically ranges from one to three weeks
recordings are then studied to provide
guidance on the neural underpinnings of
the patient's disorder and to guide the
next steps of treatment
the
intracranial electrodes themselves are
not designed to provide treatment
directly
so we're using them for the same ends in
treatment resistant depression
um this is the structure of the study
the study is led by three pis senior
chef nader peradian and wayne goodman
samir and and nader are the
neurosurgeons at baylor college of
medicine in houston in
university of texas southwestern in
dallas
dr goodman
is the chair of the psychiatry
department at baylor college of medicine
we receive psychiatric support from
sanjay matthew and kayla bailey
i direct the neuroscience efforts
particularly focusing on the
intracranial monitoring period at baylor
we receive engineering support from
brown university assessment tool support
from
from upmc and from the university of
chicago and then device support from
boston scientific and we have also a
critical collaboration with cameron
mcintyre and angela naker at duke
so i'd like to show this video clip to
demonstrate the process a little bit the
study enrolls patients with treatment
resistant depression that has failed to
respond to a variety of prior adequate
therapies we study the underlying brain
state in these cases and then we apply
initial stimulation through the deep
brain stimulation leads indicated here
in yellow
and characterize the change in network
activity
as you can see in the recording here
indicated in yellow
the change in the network that is
directly evoked by the simulation and
then also the more passive change in
just the actual resting native
electrophysiological state of the brain
after the patient has received
stimulation pulses
after 10 days of study as you saw the
seg electrodes come out the pulse
generate pulse generators are implanted
subclavicularly and the patient begins a
chronic outpatient dbs treatment
optimization phase
so in this study we have two main goals
we want to understand the
pathophysiological state of treatment
resistant depression then we want to
take a data-driven approach to the
development of stimulation programming
parameters that are individualized to
these patients
from their own brain recording
a little more information about the
stereo eeg sampling so these electrodes
are implanted broadly we sort of
designed the study that we had some
brain regions that we were interested in
the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex the
intermedial prefrontal cortex orbital
frontal both medial and lateral
the dorsal anterior cingulate cortex and
the amygdala
this approach has evolved quite a bit
through our collaboration with dr
mcintyre
at duke so here you can see um
our use in the study
of the microsoft hololens platform and
the what we call the hollow seed
approach which is developed by dr
mcintyre
and his lab at now at duke
so what you can see projected in the
middle of the space here is the
patient's actual
t1 brain scan and the patient-specific
probabilistic tactography the the white
matter fibers of the patient's brain
itself
so everyone is standing in the room
together
wearing the same holographic
headsets and then we're able to see and
manipulate this three-dimensional brain
volume together and basically step
through
the surgery
virtually to plan it
so we use the patient-specific
tactography to define the implant
targets using methods that have been
existing in the literature developed by
dr mcintyre and dr mayberg at emory
for the fcc we are targeting the
confluence of
some major fiber systems including the
forceps minor the cingulum bundle and
uncertainty fasciculus and then we're
using a similar but like new approach
to define the vcbs target that is based
on maximizing engagement to the fibers
of the anterior limb that innervate the
orbital frontal and ventral medial
prefrontal cortices
and this method
has just recently been published in
thanks at all 2022
and then
in the holographic planning space we're
able to then use
dr mcintyre's biophysical modeling of
the volume of tissue activated
to identify for example if we put the
scc leads in this patient in this spot
and then we turn on the stimulation
what are the fibers that are going to
intersect with that volume of
stimulation then we can project those
fibers out and then
in patient-specific space
plan the stereo eeg trajectory to
traverse the terminations of that fiber
system that we anticipate to be
modulating and so that's the way that
the
final placement of the seg electrodes is
implemented for each patient
so as a summary of the philosophy of the
study we believe that network disorders
like psychiatric disorders demand a
network-based therapy
and the use of epilepsy-style
intracranial recordings provide a unique
perspective into network activity and
help us characterize the effects of
stimulation
individualization of imaging and
electrophysiological analyses will
hopefully drive
improved outcomes for patients
okay so
the next part of the talk i'd like to
focus on the 10-day intracranial study
phase
so after implantation patients are moved
to the neurophysiological monitoring
unit
here you can see a sketch of how the
time runs where we start out on days one
and two with pretty basic brain
recordings at rest and during behavioral
tasks that are related to depression
before we begin an exploration of
stimulation parameter space starting
with short stimulation durations at
single contacts on individual leads and
slowly working up toward longer and
multi-lead stimulation paradigms over on
days seven and eight and culminating
with repeats of this cognitive task
during task specific individualized
stimulation parameter application
which lets us evaluate our capacity to
differentially modulate portions of the
network corresponding with different
aspects of the patient's depressive
phenomenology
in the next slides i'll show some
examples of our methods for decoding the
neural state that corresponds with the
affect of neuroscience tasks that we run
and for developing targeted approaches
to stimulation parameter recommendation
but first i just wanted to spend a
couple of minutes
talking about the overall outcome of the
case in our first patient whose data is
displayed here as you can see the
patient underwent increasing stimulation
over the period of the intracranial
monitoring phase and over the course of
this this instantaneous depression scale
rating plotted here in blue
dropped over time with the top
stimulation parameters evoking
self-reported serenity calm and focus
increased energy and social engagement
and in several conditions the patient
remarked that if he felt this way all
the time he would be much better at work
and in his personal life
the patient has gone on to a phenomenal
clinical response and has demonstrated a
discontinuation response consistent with
dbs efficacy in treating his
depression a little bit more information
about our stimulation parameter space
exploration so
during the intracranial monitoring phase
we apply
single pulse stimulation to characterize
the structure of the network
the longest stimulation that we do is
actually a 16-hour long experiment
spread over multiple days in which we
sample across um
three frequencies and three levels of
pulse width charge balanced with
amplitude and across seven current
directions we do this individually for
each of the four dbs leads
and when i say current directions i'm
referring to
the
the fact that we're using the boston
scientific cartesia lead system which is
a segmented steerable dbs lead system so
we're able to sample from the deepest
and the most superior contacts as a
solid ring and a bullet tip respectively
and then the middle two contacts are
actually segmented such that we're able
to direct current for example to the
anterior facing stack the medial facing
stack with the lateral facing stack
we're interested in this because it
allows us greater refinement in the
white matter fibers that we think we're
engaging and potentially with
directionality
to the orientation of the applied field
that then could correspond with
different engagement of different fiber
systems
then we move into a 15 second
stimulation experiment
which is designed in a slightly
different way of a different purpose
than the one second stimulation one
second is
randomized to the level of trials so
each applied one second stimulation
parameter combination is different from
the one that will follow it this is to
counterbalance against temporal drift in
the recording
and potential follow-on effects from one
stimulation to the next
the 15-second experiment is actually
designed to help us quantify um
behavioral effects of different
stimulation parameter combinations and
so for this we do 15 seconds of
stimulation on followed by five seconds
of stimulation off
it starts with single lead and then
builds up into a multi-lead stimulation
approach
and after the application of
10 trials of these 15 seconds like in
each parameter combination there's a
brief psychiatric interview so during
the duration of this experiment the
psychiatrist is sitting with the patient
and after the
the period of the stimulation the
psychiatrist does a brief
interview just asking did you notice any
change
do you like how is your mood how is your
energy um using the words that are
specific to the way the patient
describes their own phenomenology
and then toward the end we do a longer
stimulation these are um
multi-lead for a longer duration to
allow the patient to sort of get a sense
of the feeling of stimulation in a more
chronic way as a preview of what they
might expect in their outpatient
programming phase
so one of the tasks that we use in the
intracranial monitoring period is called
the affective bias task the task in
which the patients rate the intensity
and valence of presented emotional
facial expressions
we use this task
to characterize at the level of each
electrode as shown here in these
spectrograms
the response of neural activity across
frequency space and we can see here
differential responses to happy versus
sad facial expressions where this on the
left side indicated at the top with
positive is the
the neural response to happy faces and
on the right panel of the spectrogram
is the neural response to sad faces
we can examine then all the electrodes
responses together to see spatial
patterns indicated in the right-hand
column
spatial patterns across the network and
this task is showing robust patterned
responses distinguishing between the
viewing of negatively valence and
positively valence facial expressions
these data and others are then used to
build neural state signatures to compare
against the neural responses to
stimulation
we're also able to use the property of
affective biasing itself
in the study so just to speak a little
more about that affective bias refers to
the phenomenon wherein people interpret
emotional stimuli in a manner consistent
with their own internal emotional state
so patients with depression when they're
asked to rate an array of emotional
faces they'll rate them more negatively
than those same patients would rate them
after an effective round of
antidepressant therapy
and they also rate the faces more
negatively than a normative
population of healthy control
participants and so we're able to use
this response property of affective
biasing
and explore it as a function of valence
and intensity of the stimuli as well as
using it as a readout of the
neuromodulatory impact of stimulation on
mood
um another application of the affective
bias task is looking at um the it as a
network quantification um so looking at
alpha band and theta band activity on
the first day that the task is
implemented prior to any stimulation
being applied
and then looking at it again after the
accumulation of multiple days of
long-form stimulation so this is day two
of the intraoperative period versus day
nine
and so here you can see
plotted in the red dots um this
indicates that there's greater power in
these indicated contacts for positive
faces
um and the blue dots indicate greater
power in response to viewing negative
faces
so
we're interpreting this as some evidence
that just the exposure to stimulation
itself may be shifting the brain's
response to affective stimuli
um
sort of wholesale on the on the global
scale
another task that we use to characterize
the neural state is the emotional brain
behavior quantification where patients
view emotional video clips and rate
their valence intensity and familiarity
again we're able to record across the
network during the task
and we can
in the video task we can decode the time
component in panel c
against the ongoing action
of the video clip in panel d so here you
can see the um in panel d the ratings of
the
ongoing action in the video clip are
getting happier corresponding with that
same time course in panel c
theta power is actually increasing in
the brain network that we're monitoring
so
we're able to then use these data to
build a classifier which we've been
able to use to distinguish between the
neural response to happy and sad
video clips and so far these neural
responses and the classifier shows good
discriminability
the last part of the approach i'd like
to describe is one of now several
methods that we've developed
for using the intracranial
electrophysiology to describe to drive
individualized stimulation parameter
selection
so the way the process works kind of
globally is that we characterize power
in each electrode in each stimulation
condition
so we define a desired state indicated
in panel one in the yellow
this can be a naturalistically observed
positive mood state
it can be
the viewing of positive video clips the
viewing of happy facial expressions and
the bias task
the receipt of a reward during our
probabilistic reward task
and so we define anyway a desired state
and characterize
the
power across canonical frequency bands
in all of our recording electrodes
during that desired state and then we
search across the neural responses in
that frequency band
to all of the applications of
stimulation that we have tried during
the stimulation parameter search and
then we're just ranking them in terms of
the degree of match between the matching
the correlation matrices
by
condition and by frequency to optimize
the match between the desired neural
state and the
neural state evoked by the stimulation
parameters and then we iteratively fit a
generalized linear model to optimize the
stimulation parameters to evoke that
state so this is a way of looking at the
strongest contributions of the model
where we're able to see
the highest beta weights the sort of
strongest contributions to the
predictivity of the correlation matrix
between the desired state and the
stimulation of hope state strongest
contribution is driven by electrode
contact configuration so which of the
actual electrodes
on the dbs lead were stimulated is the
strongest predictor and the second
strongest predictor is the frequency
with um smaller contributions from pulse
width and amplitude
and then an exploratory approach that
we're using um is dimensionality
reduction to try to
interpret the neural state so we're able
to kind of plot and see
for example defining a
healthy versus a thick resting state and
then plotting
the
the neural features corresponding with
the different stimulations that we apply
you can see with the right scc medial
stimulation we're not really changing
the neural state very much from the sick
resting state whereas when we stimulate
the right scc in the more lateral
contact
we're evoking kind of a separate state
altogether
so it's
physically sort of discriminable and
distinct from the well state but it's
also separate from the sick state
okay so now changing gears a little bit
again to the our multimodal
investigation of mechanisms so this is
looking at
methods for pairing the
electrophysiology with the neuroimaging
data to tell us more about the structure
of the network
so this is the work of josh atkinson a
postdoc in samir chef's lab and evie
solaki a postdoc in native paradians lab
so in this experiment we're applying
single pulses of stimulation to dbs
target structures
and we understand that the application
of single pulses generates axonal
depolarization and triggers action
potentials to propagate through the
affected circuitry and result in
neurotransmission events in the cortex
and the gray matter structures
um
so where we understand that the single
pulse stimulation is able to give rise
to both orthodomic so liking to along
the main axis of the axon and also
antidramic so backwards toward the cell
body
of
of any axon that is being engaged
and that it's able to drive firing
through multi-synaptic circuits
and that this engagement may not map
completely onto the
properties that are being modeled by
diffusion tensor imaging this is
important because diffusion tensor
imaging is being used
um broadly by the field for
stimulation targeting
for um surgical lead placement um
including by our group but then
also
for understanding what we think the
effect of stimulation um and dbs is on
the network we're only through diffusion
tensor imaging able to quantify
the sort of monosynaptic like
structurally
integrated white matter fibers
that
may not
transmit through to the next level
okay so the way that we are approaching
this you can see that we can use the
patient-specific probabilistic
tractography to visualize the structural
connectivity
that's expected from the just from the
patient's dti so here you can see in
panel a the volume of tissue activated
engages the forceps minor in the
cingulum bundle then when we implant an
seg electrode in the terminations of the
forceps minor
we're able to actually do the experiment
apply a single pulse on the implanted
dbs lead and then record from
the
the seg lead that's in the termination
area of the forceps minor and that's
what you're seeing actually then tested
in panel b you can see the stimulation
artifact is very quick and then we're
seeing a positive going
waveform that starts around 19
milliseconds and then a negative going
phase around 40 milliseconds so this is
the evo potential that is generated and
recorded in basically orbital frontal
cortex following stimulation to this
structure
and then panel c and d are showing
our ways of
measuring the prediction
of the network from the diffusion tensor
imaging where red is indicating the
number of streamlines anticipated to
reach from the stimulation volume to the
recording positions
and then panel d is the actual
evo potential that we were recording so
there's quite a bit of discontinuity
between the two actually where we see
much stronger responses
in sort of orbital frontal cortex
and
sort of a lack of correspondence to
other structures that were anticipated
to be
structurally connected to this from the
diffusion tensor imaging
and then in panels e and f um it's
another way of looking at this so across
the top the labels are indicating the
listening areas basically so the orbital
frontal cortices medial and lateral the
ventrimedial prefrontal cortex amygdala
anterior cingulate and the dorsal
prefrontal cortex you can see again sort
of
in the upper panels the streamline
predictions and in the lower panel f
is the actual evoked responses where
blue is an evoked response and white is
at the absence of an evoked response
and here you can see strong
correspondence in the orbital frontal
cortexes in the ventrimedial prefrontal
cortex and then a lack of correspondence
actually in the anterior cingulate where
it was
anticipated to have
streamlined connectivity but then we
don't see the corresponding
evoked potentials
this is interesting to us
so we've now replicated this across our
first two patients
and we're able to dig into this
phenomenon a little bit more
so just to explain this figure
a little more the labels across the top
are the same sort of listening areas of
the seg electrodes and then the columns
on the left hand side are the different
applications of stimulation the upper is
the subclosal cingulate and the lower is
the ventral capsule central striatum
stimulation target
the upper half of each is the left and
the lower half is the right
and then panel a
in each is the streamlines where warmer
colors indicate greater predicted
streamline connectivity from the
simulation volume to the listening
volume
and b is showing the actual evoked
potentials from stimulation that we
applied at each of the stimulation
combinations shown in the um
in the index here
and
so there's a lot to look at but the gist
here for what really stood out to us and
looking at it is again this anterior
cingulate thing right where the fcc is
anticipated to
generate engagement in the anterior
cingulate based on the streamlines and
we see really very little of that
bear itself out in panel b
with the evoked potentials it's um
really fairly minimal whereas sort of
the opposite is observed with the
ventral capsule central striatum there's
nothing in our
in our streamline models or anything
that would predict that we would have
anterior cingulate engagement and yet we
actually have fairly strong ipsilateral
evoked potentials where when we
stimulate the vcvs on the left we're
getting evoked potentials in the left
acc
when we stimulate
the vcbs on the right we sort of get the
same thing um acc on the right evoked
potentials
so
the
just to recap this so that
it's an interesting point of divergence
between the streamlines and the evoked
potentials in the dorsal anterior
cingulate
streamlines are anticipated
or are able to predict robust engagement
of the acc
most likely by means of the cingulum
bundle but we see virtually no evo
potentials in that structure
whereas the vcvs streamlines indicate
there are no fiber tracks directly
innervating the anterior cingulate but
we still see robust evoked potentials
that arise from stimulation to the vcbs
this double dissociation has interesting
implications just for our understanding
of prefrontal networks that are
modulated in dbs
single pulse stimulation can give rise
to action potentials as i mentioned in
both directions
and it can also drive firing of neural
assemblies through polysynaptic
innervation patterns that may not just
show up through the diffusion sensor
imaging itself
um
to our knowledge though this study
represents the first evidence of dorsal
acc being directly impacted
by ventral capsule ventral striatum
stimulation perhaps providing a novel
target for closed loop recording or
stimulation in future trials
overall our findings underscore the need
for deeper understanding in both
connectivity modalities particularly
focusing on reconciling the current
findings with an in-depth histological
study of the anterior cingulate to
demonstrate responsiveness to deep brain
stimulation
um going back to the bigger picture
using this multimodal integration we're
also able to sort of quantify the degree
of convergence between the predictions
of dti and the actuality of the applied
stimulation and corresponding evoked
potentials
so we see overall a quite strong
predictive relationship between the
streamlines and the evoked potentials in
our first two patients here indicated
as patient a and patient b when we look
at this segregated by stimulation target
we can actually see separation between
the scc and the vcbs in both patients
and now this is with all appropriate
caveats that you know only two patients
looking at the receiver operating
characteristics and the the nature of
the
differences in that predictive
relationship
we're not at this point able to
make any claims related to the
statistical significance or robustness
of this but it is certainly raising
questions for us and and contributing to
our um
ongoing hypothesis testing in this area
where we're seeing a sort of a stronger
predictive relationship
between lines and the evoked potentials
in the subclosal cingulate than we are
seeing in the ventral capsule ventral
striatum
and a step back even further um as a
final plug
just in the the scientific utility and
validity of the the stereo eeg approach
um you know the ongoing use of stereo
eeg and epilepsy
and its use
for intracranial research over the past
20 years
has produced a large body of
previously collected data which then
we're able to
cross compare with the new data that is
coming from the
the clinical trial in treatment
resistant depression so this is one of
the first applications of stereo aeg for
anything other than epilepsy
but it is not the case that we have no
depression sampling so epilepsy is
frequently comorbid with depression and
so because of that property and
similarity in the implantation locations
of the trd study with what
naturally clinically comes up in
patients with epilepsy
we're able to then build
our understanding and settle some really
old questions about the value of
intracranial recording in epilepsy
patients one of the questions was
what's the value of characterizing the
intracranial electrophysiology during
cognitive neuroscience tasks in patients
with epilepsy when we think they have
ongoing abnormalities in their
electrophysiology because of their
epilepsy and so we're able to
tease this apart a little bit because we
can do these recordings in similar
implantation
coverage
patients
in groups with epilepsy groups with
epilepsy plus depression and patients
with only depression and we can see
for example
uh indications of where the network
response is similar so in response on
the affective bias task to happy faces
we see a very similar response across
depression epilepsy plus depression and
just epilepsy
suggesting that the epilepsy
itself is not necessarily driving the
electrophysiological responses that
we're measuring in this model system
um
so overall the stereo eeg approach we're
very excited about it not necessarily as
a permanent
precursor to dbs for depression but as a
data and um
and hypothesis generating tool for the
future of science that really the data
that are collected in the sample of
patients in our current uh 3 study are
anticipated to inform our understanding
of the structure of the network for many
years to come
and we hope that this will advance over
time into an understanding of network
response to stimulation and optimization
of stimulation
that can result over time in less
invasive approaches for patients and
greater patient-specific optimization of
dbs for better scientific outcomes and
clinical outcomes
i just want to thank the members of my
lab brian metzger the postdoc maddie
mackey the phd student research
assistants for t calva and brian swee
who contributed tremendously to this
work
and the amazing baylor intracranial
neuromodulation group
and the
baylor intracranial neuromodulation
group led by samir schaff and wayne
goodman
including post-docs and graduate
students and research assistants
the neurosurgery fellows
the radiology staff
and
the many many people
and grant mechanisms that have supported
this work over the years and a specific
thank you to the um
pis of the uh three study dr chef
peradian and goodman and then the um the
key investigators cameron mcintyre jeff
cohn sanjay matthew and dave borton
thanks for your time
you